I want to emphasize to you like what
we've done here is not just oh it's
curious that's kind of nice good morning
it's also like what you've got here is a
series of results that you can fuse in
the same way as you can use kind of like
a through acceleration you know we have
all our different ways you say
acceleration right and you use each one
you select on the basis of like what do
you want to know and what do you what
happen firm ation have you been given so
if you like fun if I want to find out
you know a displacement and one given
his velocity then maybe you use V DV on
DX because that's got all the pieces in
it that you need right in the same way
looking at this right for instance if
you want to find the tension ok then
obvious place that goes and L Omega
squared right it's not the only place
you can go for example just suppose you
don't know what the buildings of your
streams which would be very unusual in a
conical pendulum question because like
one of the main things testified but
suppose you don't know that suppose you
don't do that well that's not the only
way you can find tension all right like
you can find the tension this way if you
know what the angle was and you knew
what r was and that's because if you
know what the angle and RR then you can
work out all right l is applied the
fades back I in the same way if you
wanted to find out the angle what is
this son this angle 40 then you might
say well where could I go right well if
I know these two things then I can find
the angle if I know these things then I
can find the angle so you have a series
of choices that you have to make based
on what information you presented and
what is your goal does that make sense
so I want you to as we go through
hundreds your questions to example swing
as we do these two examples if you can I
like to you have you have this page open
to the side so you can refer to it one
of the reasons why we did all in general
numbers so that we can see here are the
results that can be used I think these
are probably the two most frequent ones
that come up because a lot of what we
did elsewhere was to get to these like
for example this one I highlighted in
blue do you remember how I got it you
can see it for do remember I yeah it
came from me combining the horizontal
and vertical forces here right you
divide them through and you
relationship out the money okay so have
that they're ready to refer to and then
I want you to have a look at question
one with me okay can you read with me
it's a fairly simple setup as we read
will get the important details down so
this is number one it's in point form a
conical page herbs string is 1.4 meters
long okay that's important so I'm gonna
write down now because 1.4 meters okay
the most of its particle is 10 kilograms
so I've got this kg okay by the way just
a minor point I know we all pretty much
always use em for mass right like weight
force mg all that kind of lead anyone I
suggest y like I'm trying to be a
statistic as possible that i'm not going
to say at this point M equals ten
kilograms anyway yeah because it's like
where you're just asking for it um I
could if I want to go all the way say oh
yeah it's what people meters but I think
this is more common I just thought what
a in the middle of an exam that I'm
rushing and I've got pressure misri my
own you know Oh at one point for content
is that what it means that do not eat up
the bass the particle is that the semi
vertex angle of the comb is 30 degrees
ok so the semi vertex angle and you may
like to draw your cone no just the angle
at the vertex is just this whole angle
here which is why the semi vertex angle
is half of it right so I need to mature
stuff on here though so I'm going to put
my vertical there's the center of
version right there so there's the
center that's where your particle is and
the semi vertex angle is in here it's
the angle from the vertical another way
they'll say that is what is the egg was
inclination from the vertical it's like
well measure from there and then measure
outwards ok now they've said 30 degrees
but i think that allows
to express it well how would you like me
to write it instead I on six I on six we
are all going to be talking me raise
we're going to calculus here so radians
the oly appropriately so i'm going to
put pile on six-year now that I've drawn
my diagram I might as well put on 1.4
here you want it immediately where would
I put this where is this going to factor
in he should be a my diagraph
whereabouts it's gonna be the weight
force right it's going to be a way for
so this guy down here is mg which in
this context is tension okay so far so
good but we've got all the information
now come the questions good morning find
the period of rotation and the tension
industry find the period of rotation and
the tension industry so here are the
questions ? to tension question okay now
even if it's question 1 even the
simplest conical pendulum questions are
non trigger okay they take some serious
thought and up and work here right so I
think the most important thing the
hardest part of this for us at the
beginning is just to work our path
through this um you've you've heard me
say this trend many times as we go
further into maths right the bats itself
like what makes questions hard like
computation and refugee in a draw those
things sort of recede its word up can
you interpret and choose a path you need
a workout strategy fitters okay so let's
take them one at a time it does make
sense to do them food and then tension
the period of motion that's how long it
takes to go one full revolution in this
circle okay so what is period defined by
what quantity do I need to know to find
out the period okay hold on a second the
period of motion depends on how fast
it's going around do you agree with that
right it doesn't really care about the
radius of the circle it just
about how fast you're going right so the
radius doesn't affect that right thank
you all i need is angular velocity all
they need is a bigger okay so here's my
first view that the period issues period
is defined by Omega right if you fight
Omega you'll find the period by the way
if you can't remember the period is 2pi
on Omega because that's how many radians
you around and this is how many really
if you're doing per second ok so that's
fine now you look at the question omegas
not given to you ok so then you have to
say okay well I've gotta find Omega so
what is omega divided by now here you
have time this is why I asked you to get
your working from yesterday have a look
back at your working at all the results
that we derived yesterday there's a
couple of different there's two distinct
ways that you can find out what Omega is
there to watch is more but there's two
important ones where it's at I here's
where Omega comes up in an equation and
if I know these other bits of the
equation i can find out Omega okay so
the first one I see is maybe you see it
the first one is this guy right this is
the first one you should see right this
is true if I know these are the things
I'll find Omega except as you can
quickly realize this is a bit of it done
it's a bit of a dead end at least at the
moment because to find out maybe here I
need mass good I need late for the
string good oh okay so you like okay I
can't use this yet because i don't know
the tension right so i'm going to put
this in my back pocket just for now and
say don't use it yet use it when we get
to this part okay so I'm like all right
I would just sort of put that aside for
a bit how else can I find what other
equations do I have that have a mega
yeah good work okay so this is another
equation that I have which relate Omega
the angular velocity to other things in
the situation and clearly you can see oh
this is a better choice this is a better
choice because look I know what theater
is I don't theater is Jesus concert I
know what r is as well right well I'd
rather I can do what artist ah intern is
defined by ok here's our down here right
look I've got our reigning triangle here
so what are defined by its defined by
theta and the leg ok so if R is defined
by the angle and the length of the
stream I finally got to I finally done
all the way down oh cool I know these
things now I've got a pathway the
question yes um well when I when I have
a look I guess who just in terms of like
is it easier um the short answer is off
the top my head I don't know but when
you had a look at how I went through
this right what did you say a cheers g
on Omega square ok so yes okay well if
you if you go if you go that part right
good morning so you said up so he's like
another option H so G boy ok um can we
use this was like okay I know what she
is that's good that's a constant I need
to know what 'he is well how am I going
to get h I'm still going to be yeah yeah
Jason so I'm still going to use its much
I feel as much as a path yeah okay and
this is one of the one of the things as
you can see like we've got many parts
through this question I kind of prefer
that I think these two require less work
to get to them like in terms of deriving
lives so they're sort of more
fundamental results to use ok so what
I'm going to do is I'm just going to
walk you through this now but I've gone
I'm very welcome to see how people just
go a different way it's all good but now
this is what I wanted so I'm like to get
this i leave this to get this on me and
all these other things to get those on
in this ok so now this is where I'm
going to begin ok and this step this
this is what I'm dwelling on this right
if you're going ahead of you to read a
solution right the solution will say
something like I will relate these guys
straight away right and it'll be able
what will obey it be sine theta equals R
on L right in fact revised will write
that this is my solution sine beta
equals our help right but if you're
coming to this solution right and you're
like I'm supposed to find the period Hey
look at this you like what why what made
you think that right and the answer is
going through this process made you
think that ok if you ever encountered
that experience we've got a real
solution it's just like I table makes
sense but I don't get I don't get why
they've done any of that ok it's because
this process doesn't usually get written
down this process is usually in
someone's brain look